well I you know I like to say that we
need a certain degree of polarization
that democracy really depends upon
having a certain degree of polarization
so that voters can choose between the
parties based on which set of policies
you really support and I think today
it's pretty clear I think what the
parties stand for people for the most
part I think understand the differences
between the Democratic and Republican
parties and they feel that there's a lot
at stake in these elections and
therefore that tends to increase the
level of interest certainly polarization
can go too far and you know in a
democratic political system it's
important that those who are defeated
have to recognize and accept the
legitimacy of the winners and the
winners have to understand that you know
those who lost the last election may be
back in power in the future and what
we're seeing now in American politics is
that sometimes the the rhetoric I think
it's so heated that you know there's a
tendency to sometimes question the
legitimacy of the other side and we've
seen this on both sides that both among
Democrats and Republicans as a tendency
to question the legitimacy of the of the
other party and the other side to
question the the loyalty of the other
side the patriotism of the other side
you know so that kind of inflamed
rhetoric can sometimes also lead to
threats of violence you know and I think
that is very unfortunate so I think
while having
clear differences between the parties is
a good thing I think that some of the
overheated rhetoric and personal
animosity that we've seen in recent
years is really not desirable